what kind of bonuses do you guys want so
I'm really excited because I'm starting
to move into marketing mode with the
book is a few final things I got to
figure out on the content inside the
book but it's mostly with the publisher
now and in two weeks I have a call with
the publisher to figure out the
marketing strategy i'm so excited about
it and one of the things i need to
figure out that i could use your help on
is what are the bonuses that you want to
see so a lot of times when people buy
books for authors especially in the
pre-order phase if you buy one book you
obviously just get the book but if you
buy five books you get something in ten
books you get something in 20 books you
get something than 100 books you get
something and a thousand books you get
something all the way up and so I'm
curious what kind of bonuses you guys
would like to see because I'm going to
take that information in and very likely
you're going to see those kind of
resulted in the pre order or special
page it'll be like this bonus page you
can go to has all the options you can
pick what's right for you in something
fun right beyond just getting extra
copies of the book to be able to give
away and influence your friends and give
them some ideas to help them grow but
some other kind of fun bonus for you to
be able to realize as a thank you for me
for the support so really curious about
your ideas if you have something that
you haven't commented before now's the
time leave in the comments below because
I could really use your feedback now
let's get to your questions first up is
Paul Chan wow what energy doing three
videos a day right book and run Toronto
salsa new Superman your team is awesome
things yeah I mean I super appreciate
that understand that I have a team that
helps me with everything on my business
I have 16 people on the salsa business I
have a team of people too so you may see
me as the frontman for a lot of stuff
but there's a lot of people working
behind the scenes to make all that
happen when I was just in the YouTube
channel myself I was doing a video a
week because I was filming and editing
and recording and doing everything so
being able to bring on a team can really
help you ramp up your growth and it
doesn't I'm not Superman it's not me
doing everything is that there's a huge
strong group behind me that's really
helping me out yasmine Lyon wrote in to
say i love you you're so authentic I'm
so
your book this is what's actually super
interesting I haven't talked about what
the book is about which hopefully is
coming soon super excited people to do
that for you guys and it's interesting
how many people are willing to just buy
blindly because they love the channel
and they love what I'm about and I think
one as a lesson for you guys that's what
authenticity will help you with people
will want to buy your products or
services regardless of before they even
know what it's about because they love
you and so the more you bring your story
to your business and not just hide
behind some corporate professional story
the more likely people will connect with
you and want to buy your stuff I'm also
curious I don't know if we have time to
run it but i'm curious to offer some
supreme bonus for people who are willing
to buy it without me talking about what
the book is about i wonder if we'll do
it as a fun test I don't know maybe but
I think you've really appreciate it next
up Michael who wrote as always another
very well broken down an extremely
useful video looking forward to the book
thank you one of the things that I find
interesting and that I try to do on
these videos is always try to provide
value so even a question like this where
it's not really a question is just a
compliment saying that they liked the
video trying to provide value in each
answer for you guys watching that
hopefully you can learn something to
apply it to your business and I think if
you can take comments that people give
you and then try to go a little bit
deeper so even at the comment is just
something saying nice things about you
you could turn that into an opportunity
to further help the person or to share
that story the posted to social media
share it with your team is always a way
to take the things that come in and go a
little bit deeper with it to help not
just you but help the people around you
and also help your business grow so I
really appreciate the support i'm glad
that you love the videos and thought do
you think that their detailed and broken
down even though it's really just like
random questions being thrown at me but
really appreciate that in the support
next up and i'm a pro 100 i want to
write books in the future as well but
english isn't my first language can you
give me some tips and how it can write a
book and publish it i'm pretty sure you
have a video on it somewhere it'd be
sweet to have a link so a couple things
here first i want to figure out why you
write in the book the why is always
super important is it that you just want
to have this book off your bucket list
you cross it off say i wrote a book
you'll show people is it to try to
improve your credibility so you get more
speaking gigs or more customer
as clients is it that you want to have
an impact and wanted to reach a ton of
people is it that you're trying to make
money and you see it as an opportunity
to get your message out there and make
money in the process the Y impacts the
direction you go if you're just trying
to make money if you just want to have a
book then the easiest way to do it is to
self-publish just get it out there right
you can cross off your bucket list
you'll make way more money from
self-publishing than you will fly going
through traditional publisher I didn't
do that i went with penguin Random House
because the money wasn't what was
driving me it's the impact I wanted to
reach people like I reach people through
my youtube channel I reach people
through the seminars and conferences
that I do I wanted to reach people
through the book I wanted you know some
people don't watch videos they prefer to
pick up a book and read and so I want to
be able to impact more people's lives
and so traditional publishing was the
way that I went even though it's not as
lucrative at least in the short term and
so first figure out your why then the
language does it have to be in English I
mean the market is limited if it's not
English English biggest language easiest
to get publishers you just to get some
breakthrough on but maybe you can start
in your own local language if not it was
English then maybe you need to partner
with somebody to translate it for you
maybe you take your message and find
somebody who you'll go splits with they
take ten percent of the sales if they
translate all the content for you into
english in terms of finding a publisher
the hardest thing to do with publishers
is the first-time author is get on the
radar is to get people to care the
reason why the publisher came to me was
interested was because of my following
you know is the first-time author
usually publishers don't care about you
and they won't give me in advance
because your first time out they got to
prove yourself where they'd rather work
with so many more establishing
traditional and publishers are doing
less and less work to actually get the
book out it's becoming more the author's
job to promote it and bring in the sales
and so they want to see that you have an
audience and you have people behind you
who if you put something out they would
want to buy and so if you don't have
that yet now is the time to start
building it I've been doing this book
series for I don't know how many weeks a
year and it's still not out it's coming
out not for another half a year until
December that could all be time that you
use to build your social media following
I'm still going to build up my channel
my channel we be way bigger in six
months than it is right now and so as
you're writing the manuscript as you're
getting everything together you want to
make
here you also have the marketing to
follow it with and so like start
investing your time right now because
that's part of the book publishing world
if you want to deal with a traditional
publisher next up is yan this is the
fifth day of the BTA challenge and I'm
feeling good so the BTA challenge is
something that I started as I wanted
people to be able to wake up in the
morning with a goal that was easy to
keep on because if you stick to one
habit you're more likely to stick to the
other habits that you have if you have a
habit of you want to stick to these
habits of waking up and drinking some
water and working out and doing a
meditation and you know knocking a big
thing off your list for work and that's
how you want to start your day what
often happens if you wake up and you
skip that morning workout you're going
to skip everything else like ah you know
I skip that and so I don't feel like
doing the next thing I'll just get back
on track tomorrow whereas if you do the
first thing you're much more likely to
follow through on everything else you're
much more likely to eat healthy and do
your meditation do whatever else is on
your list if you do that first thing so
I wanted to help provide the spark for
the first thing what I wanted people to
do was come to the channel be inspired
learn something to help them grow
personally or in their business and then
leave a comment with your bt a number to
represent how many days in a row that
you're doing it and hopefully if you
keep being consisted on that then you
that'll be the lightning spark to be
able to do the other things to all the
other habitats you've been slacking off
for letting slide now sudden you're
following through you're taking action
because the BTA was the first thing that
you did so that very first habit that
you do every morning is super important
because if you don't do it most your
other ones will slide and if you do do
it chances are the other ones will stick
so I'm super glad that you're on day
five congratulations welcome aboard and
looking forward to having that be you
know 50 and then 500 sin next up is qik
video like this video Evan thank you
like the personal stuff on your behind
the scenes how you run your days
somewhat inspirational to the extent
that your normal like the rest of us
makes you more relatable good job sir
thank you for that I put in this is an
interesting point and this hopefully can
help you with you guys in your business
to the life with Evan series where I
show me moving into the condo or me
doing something with Nina for the
weekend or just something that's
happening in my life that's behind the
scenes is the worst
performing series on my channel it gets
the least number of views it gets the
least number of subscribers a number of
the videos are negative subscribers so I
lose more subscribers than I gained on
those videos and so you know the logical
business thing to do might be to cut
that series like what's the least
performing series and let's cut that up
with something in that people want to
see you or more caring about the reason
why they're in is because it ties people
closer to me and so I may lose some of
the fringe friends but it helps the
super fans get to know me more and it's
important for your business because I
believe you need to tell your store you
need to explain why you're doing this
people need to see the passion behind
what you're all about if I'm hiring
somebody to shovel my snow you know I
want the guy who loves shoveling snow or
who's going to really take the time and
commitment to make it perfect who's
going to shovel my driveway I'm in a
Conlan now but who's going to shovel my
driveway like you whichever his mother's
driveway right like that is what I want
to see and I would pay more for that I
would pay more for that because I feel
like I'm getting a better quality
experience working with that person
where if I can't tell the difference
between you and everybody else and I'm
just gonna beat you down on price like
okay you're all the same two overs
cheapest I'm going to go with why am I
going to pay more if I can't tell the
difference between you and so injecting
the personality injecting the story
injecting why this means so much to you
matters it brings more like-minded
people to you it brings people who love
what you're all about it brings more
ideal clients to you and they're more
likely to spread the word and the mark
and to buy more from you they're likely
to buy related products from you they're
likely to tell their friends about you
and introduce you to contacts that can
help you and so even though on the
surface I me look like the worst Series
I wouldn't kill it like I love making
them and it helps tie people to me more
personally and so I think you need to do
it to tell your story make it a part of
what you do in your business next up is
Jessica can't wait for the book so far
the videos help it can't imagine the
book I can't wait for it to it's been so
long I'm so excited about it I finished
writing it a while ago and I just want
to get it out there in the people's
hands because I I read it again and I
still get motivated reading the pages in
there and there's tons of practical
advice to help you grow looking for the
making YouTube videos on it to the you
know round out the knowledge it's in
book but I'm feeling your excitement I
hope you're feeling mine and as soon as
we're ready to go I promise I will let
you guys know next up was allemaal
beauty believe nation rocks I agree it's
very interesting and I've touched us a
couple times that we have such a
positive community I know a lot of
people on YouTube have really negative
communities is a lot of hate in the
comments I think one it's partly me
being involved from the beginning I was
answering all the comments and I'm still
involved daily in the comments and to
creating content that isn't about hate
it would be so easy to make content that
look at what a bad decision this person
made or look at the top 10 Donald Trump
failures were or you know look at the
top 10 Hillary Clinton on stage blow-ups
were like all of these negativity things
we're just picking on people where
everything that I create is with
intention positive even though that
probably hurts the views I'm sure if I
put out some of those other videos I
would get more views more subscribers
but I don't want the negative vibe that
comes along with it I'm not in this just
to try to get tons of user subscribers I
want to have an impact I want people to
change their approach and change their
mind set on a lot of different things
and so you know you guys can do that too
the way your mindset is the way your
approach is the content that you produce
a product service that you put out there
how you behave is important and the
people who are around you will start to
behave in that similar way as well I
think if you're a big hater you don't
get a lot of pleasure being on my
channel so I agree we'll leave nation
rocks you guys chill me every day you
feel me with satisfaction and it's what
I look forward to every day is checking
out the comments and you guys are
leaving and also supporting each other
like I might be late jumping in the
conversation somebody has a question
like help I'm really striking with this
and like 50 you have jumped in to answer
that person and even if you can't
provide an answer just giving them
support and encouragement I love it
that's how we make the world better
entrepreneurs will make the world better
entrepreneurs will solve every global
problem that we have and you guys are
the one who's going to do it last up
Curtis Edmund I'm really interested in
how people transition from a full-time
job incha entrepreneurship two schools
of thought here one
is you know quit your job go full-time
and force yourself you know burn the
boats burn the bridges is no going back
it's doing this or I die kind of
mentality and that works for some people
the other is to ease yourself into it
and that's more than school of thought
that I'm from do it on the side do a
part-time prove to yourself that you
love it that you want to do this that
it's still exciting for you find a job
where you're going to learn not just
make money you're going to learn about
the issue that you want to get into you
want to be a photographer go work for
photographer learn the ropes work for a
small company to understand how that
industry works and see if you still want
to do it like you might go work for
Dagar and say wow I hate this I don't
want that guy's life and that's amazing
right like better to learn that while
getting paid instead of going into debt
to do it yourself the hardest part is
just being consistent when you have a
job when you have the responsibilities
it can be hard to be dedicated to your
business and you can let day slide where
you need to make sure you're spending
half an hour at least every single day
no excuses to help your business grow
and you you quit your job and go full
time on your business when one you're
not learning anything more your job like
you've learned what you needed to learn
in which case you should not be there
anymore and either go get another job or
start your business full time or two
when your business gets to the point
where you're making enough money to
support yourself not cashing it in
making huge box you're not buying
Lamborghinis but paying internet bill
having food in the fridge basics because
if your side business can just support
you and the necessities of life when
you're doing a part time then imagine
what I could do when you're going full
time so that's my advice thank you guys
so much for watching it's been another
amazing session again please leave me
your feedback on what you'd like to see
as bonuses for the books for buying
multiple copies leave it down the
comments below really appreciate all
your love and support continue to
believe and I'll see you soon